[Musik]
das grenzland zwischen russland und
norwegen sie spüren die neue eiszeit der
großmächte ex spion frohberg der fsb hat
offensichtlich eine gute übersicht über
kirkenes russlands kampfjets fordern die
nato immer wieder heraus in ihrem
hauptquartier tief drin in einem berg
beobachten norwegens militärs russlands
manöver sie haben angefangen
scheinangriffe zu fliegen und rund ums
parlament in oslo fangen unbekannte
handydaten ab zeitungsjournalisten haben
das aufgedeckt sie behaupten russlands
geheimdienste sind mit versteckten
löschgeräten im regierungsviertel
unterwegs
russland will wissen was bei uns vor
sich geht und wir wollen wissen was
passiert da im hohen norden wie waren
sie am rande der arktis hier kommen sich
nato und russland am nächsten
es ist eine region voller militärischer
geheimnisse russlands nordflotte kreuzt
hier ihr hafen murmansk ist nicht weit
entfernt vom norwegischen grenzort
kirkenes fahren wir nur ein paar minuten
bis zum übergang nach russland viel ist
hier nicht los ein paar lastwagen sonst
nur private autos der menschen aus der
grenzregion für uns ist an der grenze
ohne visum endstation
die menschen aus der region reisen ins
nachbarland zum einkaufen
die norweger fahren nach russland wegen
des günstigeren baumaterials oder
alkohols aber auch die russen kommen zum
beispiel menschen aus murmansk mit denen
wir seit jahren zu tun haben
wir empfinden die grenze nicht als
eisernen vorhang der uns hier am reisen
hindert
diesen kleinen grenzverkehr unter
nachbarn dürfen wir filmen nicht aber
die kamera auf die russische seite
richten
es ist eine höchst sensible nato
außengrenze die hoch oben am himmel von
militärjets beide seiten streng bewacht
wird
seit die russen 2014 die krim annektiert
haben sind die zeiten auch hier rauer
geworden
das spüren auch die einwohner des 3000
seelen ortes kirkenes hier besuchen wir
froh de berg der ehemalige offizier von
norwegens grenztruppen hat sich stets
für ein gutes verhältnis der menschen
auf beiden seiten der grenze eingesetzt
unter seinen russischen kollegen hatte
ja immer viele freunde
jedes mal wenn wir uns draußen im wald
zu einer besprechung getroffen hatten
haben wir uns auch zeit genommen für ein
gemeinsames essen da draußen
das endete als der 64-jährige in den
strudel einer spionageaffäre geraten war
auf drängen des norwegischen
geheimdienstes brachte er briefe
vermeintlich mit geld und speicherkarten
über die grenze die russen schnappten
und verurteilten ihn als spion zwei
jahre saß in einem moskauer gefängnis es
diesen winter kam er frei frode fühlt
sich von norwegens geheimdienst mit
braucht weil ich in russland und bei den
behörden dort gut bekannt bin hätten die
die mich um diesen gefallen gebeten
haben doch sehen müssen nein wir können
froh den berg nicht benutzen aber sie
haben froberg trotzdem benutzt
die haben mir das als völlig legale und
ungefährliche aufgabe dargestellt die
haben nie gesagt dass das etwas mit
spionage zu tun hat so was wäre für mich
nie in frage gekommen halben million
euro entschädigt denn offenbar
enthielten die vermeintlich harmlosen
briefe konkrete anweisungen an oslos
spione in wurden
welche folgen haben solche geheimdienst
manöver für das verhältnis von russland
und norwegen in der hauptstadt oslo
wollen wir mehr erfahren über das
treiben der agenten und das was von
sowas kommt oder war ein repräsentant
für die zivilgesellschaft dass man ihn
benutzt hat macht die sache gleich
doppelt problematisch
einmal weil er gar kein professioneller
spion war
und zum anderen liefert sein einsatz
russischen verschwörungstheorien nahrung
diese theorien unterstellen dass alles
was norwegen und die westlichen länder
tun für den aufbau der russischen
zivilgesellschaft eigentlichen entdeckt
operationen sind um das putin regime zum
einsturz zu bringen
hanebuth dem regime und so wächst das
misstrauen zwischen moskau und oslo wo
man sich schon lange selbst im visier
russischer geheimdienste sie ist
norwegens hauptstadt tatsächlich
tummelplatz der spione
wir treffen den reporter peter hansen
von der zeitung aftenposten
vor einiger zeit hat er aufgedeckt dass
unbekannte mitten im regierungsviertel
handy daten abfischen hier rund um das
parlament haben wir signale von mehreren
verdächtigen basisstationen aufgefangen
was darauf hindeutet dass in dieser
gegend viele handys überwacht wurden
damit konnte verfolgt werden wer zu
welcher sitzung ging man konnte
informationen über die identität des
einzelnen abfangen und spionage
programme installieren
die entsprechenden basisstationen konnte
er nicht aufspüren sie waren offenbar
mobil wurden vielleicht den koffern
rucksäcken oder sogar im baby wagen
durch die innenstadt geschoben die
stärksten signale haben wir rund um
einen platz im regierungsviertel
empfangen sowie diese basisstationen
arbeiteten ähnelten sie einem
überwachungssystem das white russian
heißt in der ukraine entwickelt und
verkauft wird und dass an vielen orten
der welt im einsatz ist
das ist billig kostet umgerechnet nur
ein paar hundert euro
nach seinen recherchen ist reporter
johannsen überzeugt das leben verdeckten
operationen der norwegischen polizei vor
allem russlands geheimdienste in oslo
die finger im spiel haben obwohl
norwegens behörden inzwischen besser
hingucken sind die lauscher wohl immer
noch aktiv ich bin mir sicher dass das
immer noch vor sich geht
ohne zweifel wir haben starke hinweise
darauf dass die russischen geheimdienste
in oslo und in norwegen in großem stil
operieren
norwegen ist russlands nato nachbarland
und die russen interessieren sich für
vieles was bei uns vor sich geht
[Musik]
die russen sind neugieriger geworden und
unberechenbare was bedeutet das für die
region in der sich nato und russland am
nächsten sind wir bekommen die seltene
gelegenheit das hauptquartier der
norwegischen streitkräfte zu besuchen
es ist tief in einem gebirge verbunkert
was auch immer passiert am himmel und im
meer rund um norwegen das haben sie hier
im hauptquartier der norwegischen
streitkräfte im blick und sie wissen
ziemlich genau was die russischen
streitkräfte zu lande zu wasser und in
der luft rund um norwegen gerade treiben
bevor wir in diesem tunnel dürfen gibt
es strenge passkontrollen
wir dürfen kein telefon nicht mal eines
smart watch mitnehmen in diesem bunker
umsehen ist erlaubt aber das militär
entscheidet was gefilmt werden darf
von hier aus erfolgt der start von
oberkommando jacobsen russlands
aktivitäten rund um die bar 2017
erlebten wir was ganz neues die russen
flogen plötzlich simulierte luftangriffe
auf norwegische einrichtungen zum
beispiel auch eine radarstation in
warten oder auf den flughafen von bode
sowas machen gute nachbarn eigentlich
nicht
38-mal sind im letzten jahr nato
abfangjäger aufgestiegen weil sich
russische maschinen norwegens grenze
genähert haben die jets sind rund um die
uhr start bereit auch tief in der nacht
kann sich generell jacobsen auf seine
piloten im dienste der nato verlassen
ich höre es von zu hause wenn die f 16
jets nachts staaten dann bekomme ich
innerhalb weniger minuten eine nachricht
von unserem diensthabenden offizier was
los ist
das ist normal und die russen machen das
übrigens nicht anders mit uns wenn wir
nördlich von cola herum fliegen dann
steigen deren jets auf und
identifizieren unsere maschinen das ist
nicht ungewöhnlich
ungewöhnlich dagegen war dass russland
während eines nato-manövers das
gps-signal störte das traf auch zivile
flugzeuge welche botschaft sendet moskau
in oslo mit derartigen machtspielen am
himmel
das ist eine art militärischer
portionierung um zu signalisieren hier
sind wir diesen stark kommt uns nicht zu
namen
aber trotzdem haben sie sich an die
regeln gehalten seit dem großen nato
manöver 2018 in norwegen beobachten wir
dass die russen unberechenbarer werden
so kündigen sie ganz plötzlich
schießübungen in der nordsee die neue
eiszeit zwischen nato und russland
lastet schwer auf den menschen im
arktischen grenzland sie wollen gute
nachbarschaft leiden aber hier ganz im
norden zunehmend unter der großen
politik wie versuchen sie dem einfluss
aus den weit entfernten hauptstädten
oslo und moskau zu trotzen
wir sind zurück in kirkenes wo sich die
menschen mehr als grenzländer stadt als
großen oder norweger sehen
es ist auch der sport sie verbindet die
trainer willi und william spiele mit
ihren teams auf beiden seiten der grenze
es geht um ringen eishockey und im guten
wir wollen dass unsere
jugendmannschaften die kultur musik und
geschichte der nachbarn lernen
deshalb nehmen wir die zwölfjährigen mit
rüber nach murmansk und trainieren dort
mit den russen in letzter zeit
allerdings werden ihre spiele ohne
grenzen zunehmend zum spielball der
weltpolitik unsere zusammenarbeit wird
ständig schwieriger militärangehörige
aller länder dürfen nicht mehr über die
grenze aber das halbe eishockey team
besteht aus soldaten
die sitzen jetzt zu hause rum das ist
das resultat der politik in oslo und
moskau die welt politik drängt immer
stärker in ihren alltag das
thematisieren sie auch beim
kulturfestival von norwegern und großen
in kirkenes sie fürchten um den
zusammenhalt in der grenzregion wollen
sich durch den spionagefall berg nicht
gegeneinander aufhetzen lassen
vor oder in kulturgruppen und in
zusammenarbeit von norwegern und russen
sehr aktiv jeder zehnte hier bei uns ist
russe hier wird laut und frei russisch
gesprochen
dürfen es hat so viele interessante
seiten
wenn eine dieser reihe nun kirkenes die
stadt der spione ist macht uns das doch
nur interessant dass sich die
geheimdienste hier oben sehr für das
jeweilige nachbarland interessieren es
den kirchen ist nicht neu bürgermeister
rohner felsen betont uns gegenüber den
zusammenhalt in der region
für ihn gehört die grenzüberschreitende
kooperation an der barentssee zum besten
was norwegens politik geleistet hat aber
hat die spionage affäre nicht doch
auswirkungen auf das leben hier
die hat mir keine auswirkungen für mich
als bürgermeister war es wichtig dass
frode zurück zu seiner familie durfte
alles andere ist uninteressant wir
müssen dafür arbeiten vertrauen zu
schaffen die menschen die hier mit
russland zusammenarbeiten müssen das
gefühl haben dass das im norwegischen
interesse ist rohde hat am eigenen leib
erfahren was passieren kann wenn man
sich mit dem diensten einlässt er ist
froh wieder zu hause zu sein und hat
gelernt die kleinen dinge des alltags zu
schätzen
dinge wie messer und gabel im gefängnis
ist man jede mahlzeit mit einem löffel
das war das einzige was wir hatten
ein löffel den mann nicht bieten kann es
ist schwierig fisch mit einem löffel zu
essen
auch hinter seiner frau anita liegen
zwei harte jahre
die unterstützung von nachbarn und
freunden war zwar groß aber hatte sie
nicht auf panik beim gedanken daran dass
ihr mann in einem russischen gefängnis
am anfang dachte ich ja dass er schnell
wieder frei kommen dass das alles nur
ein missverständnis ist
erst als die großen schlagzeilen der
zeitungen
von horror gefängnis sprachen da dachte
ich mir was ist das hier wie lange muss
er da bleibe aber das ist so lange
dauern würde
hier in kirkenes haben die beiden erlebt
wie schnell man als bewohner des
grenzlandes zum spielball der großen
politik werden kann
rodenberg ist erleichtert dass alles
hinter sich zu haben er ist wieder zu
hause
aber er hat einen hohen preis gezahlt
seine russischen freunde auf der anderen
seite der grenze sind für ihn jetzt
unerreichbar weit weg ist opfer der
neuen eiszeit zwischen russland und den
staaten der nacht
[Musik]